[Music]
reality TV is really not for me turn it
off right now I need
fantasy put that show in space with some
time
travel oh what fun it is to be with a
Sci-Fi show tonight sg1 Atlantis
Stargate
Universe give me some Babylon Five Star
Trek Star Wars of course sg1 Atlantis
Stargate
Universe give me some Babylon Five Star
Trek Star Wars of
[Music]
course
documentaries they can be quite good I
don't need to learn I need Quantum Leap
Let's Get Lost in Space fight some
aliens oh what fun it is to be enjoying
my TV oh sg1 Atlantis Stargate
Universe give me some babon 5 Star Trek
Star Wars of course sg1 Atlantis
Stargate
Universe give me some Babylon F star
treack Star Wars of course give me some
Babylon five star Track Star Wars of
[Music]
course